>> Greg: MUSK STARTS TO CLEANSE
TWITTER OF LAME COMEDIANS.
ON SUNDAY AFRICAN IMMIGRANT ELON
MUSK THREATENED TO PERMANENTLY
SUSPEND TWITTER ACCOUNTS THAT
PRETENDED TO BE SOMEONE ELSE
WITHOUT BEING AN OBVIOUS PARODY
WHICH IS WHY THE PERSON TWEETING
FOR JOE BIDEN IS SAFE.
THIS RULE WAS ALREADY IN
TWITTER'S TERMS OF SERVICE BUT
THOSE ARE READ EVEN LESS THAN
BRIAN KILMEADE'S BOOKS.
MUSK ANNOUNCED THIS AFTER
SEVERAL ATTENTION SEEKERS
STARTED IMPERSONATING HIM.
SHE TWEETED I AM A FREEDOM OF
SPEECH ABSOLUTIST AND I EAT
DOEDY FOR BREAKFAST EVERY TIME.
THANKFULLY IT'S THE FIRST TIME
SHE IMPERSONATED AN AFRICAN
WITHOUT THIS.
YEAH THIS LADY WORE BLACK FACE
AND THINKS FREE SPEECH
ABSOLUTIST IS AN INSULT.
KATHY GRIFFEN ALSO IMPERSONATING
MUSK TWEETING SHE WOULD ONLY BE
VOTING BLUE.
USERS COULD STILL TELL IT WAS
KATHY GRIFFEN BECAUSE IT WASN'T
FUNNY.
ALTHOUGH HER BAN WAS ALLEGEDLY
PERMANENT MUSK TWEETED SHE COULD
HAVE IT BACK FOR EIGHT BUCKS AND
COULD GET HER FACE BACK BY
INJECTING ALLERGY THAT EATS
PLASTIC.
I DID NOT KNOW THAT.
BUT IF YOU'RE BUMMED SHE'S GONE
AND YOU MISS HER BRAND OF COMEDY
TRY SLAMMING YOUR HEAD WITH A
CAR DOOR.
OTHERS LEFT IN PROTEST BUT ONE
IS ALREADY BACK.
APPARENTLY A WEEK AFTER
ANNOUNCING HE WAS LEAVING
TWITTER RON PULLMAN SLITHERED
BACK TO BEGIN JUST POPPED BACK
ON BECAUSE I COULDN'T LET THIS
ONE SLIDE.
YEAH HE JUST POPPED THIS BACK
ON.
HIS QUITTING IS LIKE A HUNGER
STRIKE WITH LUNCH BREAKS.
LIKE TELLING SOMEONE YOU'RE DONE
WITH THEM FOREVER BUT THEN
CALLING TO SAY YOU'RE COMING
OVER TO RETRIEVE THE BALL POINT
BENEFIT YOU LEFT AT THEIR PLACE.
WHICH REMINDS ME JAMIE I NEED
THAT PEN BACK.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S INTERESTING?
I FEEL LIKE JAMIE A LOT OF THESE
CELEBRITIES THEY KIND OF SEE --
THEY HAVE THIS ARRESTED
DEVELOPMENT SO THEY SEE
EVERYBODY LIKE THE GYM COACH
DOING DETENTION AND THEY'RE LIKE
THE BREAKFAST CLUB.
FIRST IT WAS TRUMP AND NOW IT'S
ELON MUSK.
I'M GOING TO GET BACK ON THIS
BILLIONAIRE ON TWITTER BY GOING
ON TWITTER.
>> Jamie: YEAH.
AND WHAT'S WEIRD IS I SAW
HEADLINES AND I WAS LIKE WOW IS
ELON REALLY NOT LETTING PEOPLE
JOKE AROUND.
HE JUST WANTS PEOPLE TO NOT
PRETEND THEY'RE HIM.
LIKE PARODY AND JOKES ARE
TOTALLY FINE WHICH IS KIND OF
DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY IT WAS
REPRESENTED.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO PRETEND -- FOR REAL.
I DON'T MIND HIM DOING THAT AT
ALL AS THE CEO.
I THINK HE MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
TOO ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE.
LIKE THE NUMBER ONE RULE WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO BE FAMOUS IS
LIKE DON'T READ THE COMMENTS AND
ELON IS READING THE COMMENTS.
MAYBE IT'S DONE DIFFERENTLY ON
HIS PLANET OR WHATEVER BUT I
THINK HE SHOULD NOT DO THAT.
NO JOKE, I'M A LITTLE -- I'LL
PAY $8 A MONTH BUT I THINK THE
VERIFICATION WAS VERY USEFUL
MAYBE FOR SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
HAVE EIGHT BUCKS BECAUSE IT DOES
HELP PEOPLE FROM IMPERSONATING
YOU.
THAT WAS THE ONE THING IT DOES
DO WITHOUT MARKETING.
I HAD A PERSON IMPERSONATING ME
ON TWITTER IT WAS REALLY BAD
THIS PERSON WAS AN IDIOT AND
PEOPLE TOTALLY FELL FOR IT AND
THOUGHT IT WAS ME.
HE WOULD MESSAGE PEOPLE AND SET
UP DATES AND I GOT MESSAGES
MONTHS LATER FROM WOMEN SAYING I
THOUGHT WE WERE MEETING UP.
SO I HAD TO GO THROUGH HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS -- I HAD TO SLEEP
WITH HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
WOMEN.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE TRUE HERO
IN ALL THIS.
>> Jamie: YEAH.
>> Dana: GOD BLESS.
>> Greg: DANA, WOULD YOU EVER
CONSIDER LEAVING TWITTER?
NOW I DON'T WANT TO GO.
>> Dana: SOMETIMES I DO A THEN
LIKE RON.
>> Greg: RON PERELMAN.
>> Dana: JUST GET BACK ON.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD MISS IT
THAT MUCH BUT I REALIZE I USE IT
A LOT FOR WORK.
I'M SKNTLY LOOKING WHAT IS THE
UPDATE, LOOKING FOR GUY'S TWEETS
SO I KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
BUT I ACTUALLY HAVE FOUND
THERE'S LESS OF THAT AVAILABLE.
A LOT OF IT IS KIND OF NONSENSE
NOW AND I HAVE HOPE FOR TWITTER
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
BILL HEMMER SAID HE WOULD PAY MY
$8 I MONTH SO I FIGURE I MIGHT
AS WELL STAY.
>> Greg: WOW.
HEMMER MUST LIKE YOU.
HE'S NEVER PAID FOR ANYTHING FOR
ME GUY.
>> Guy: I'M CAUGHT UP ON THE
BLACK FACE PHOTO OF SARAH
SILVERMAN WHICH I DID NOT KNOW
HAPPEN.
AM I MISTAKEN OR DID SHE NOT
DATE JIMMY CHEMLE WHO ALSO DID
BLACK FACE.
DID THEY DO BLACK FACE DATES
TOGETHER.
>> Greg: YES, THEY WOULD SHARE
THE PAINT, THEY WOULD GET THE
PAINT AND MAKE OUT AND BOTH HAVE
BLACK FACE.
>> Guy: SORRY I FORGET WA THE
TOPIC IS.
I'M JUST RUMINATING.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT INCREDIBLE
LIKE THIS SUB INDUSTRY OF BLACK
FACE COMMENTS.
THEY'RE FINE, HIS RATINGS AREN'T
FINE BUT HE'S NOT CANCELLED YET
IN EITHER WAY.
BUT THE ONE THING ABOUT ELON WAS
HIS TWEET TODAY, DID YOU SEE
THIS, WHERE HE ENDORSED
REPUBLICANS?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Guy: AND JUST A COMPLETE
TOTAL MELTDOWN ON THE LEFT.
HE SAID WE SHOULD HAVE CHECKS
AND PULSED MAYBE WE SHOULD VOTE
REPUBLICAN THIS TIME AND PEOPLE
LOST IT.
HE IS GETTING CLOSE TO TRUMP
LEVELS OF TROLLING, IT IS
IMPRESSIVE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
I THINK HE HAS TAKEN UP THE
SPACE THAT TRUMP HAD BECAUSE
HE'S IN EVERY -- YOU KNOW, KAT,
IF YOU NOTICE, EVERY SINGLE
STORY COULD BE RELATE BACK TO
NOW TWITTER OR TO MUSK.
BEFORE THAT YOU COULD RELATE I
BACK TO TRUMP
>> Kat: YEAH, THAT'S TRUE.
AND A LOT OF THE HEADLINES WERE
SAYING, YOU KNOW, SHE WAS
BANNED, KATHY GRIFFEN WAS BANNED
FOR MOCKING HIM.
IT WAS THE IMPERSONATING THING I
GET THAT.
I ALSO THINK A PERMANENT
SUSPENSION WOULD NOT BE FAIR.
I THINK SHE'S OBVIOUSLY JOKING,
THAT'S ALL SHE EVER DOES.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY GOES TO
HER FOR LIKE SERIOUS NEWS
ANALYSIS, AT LEAST I HOPE NOT.
AND IF SHE'S INTENDING TO MAKE A
JOKE THEN I THINK THAT SHOULD BE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT NO MATTER WHO
IT IS.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE REALLY
HATE KATHY GRIFFEN AND ARE HAPPY
TO SEE HER GETTING BANNED
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
MAYBE ON THE RIGHT, YOU KNOW,
THEY GOT BANNED FOR THINGS, TOO.
BUT I'M NEVER ONE FOR LIKE THE
TIT FOR TAT.
>> Greg: YOU B